140 chickens get processed every minute in
most poultry plants in the US.
That’s the maximum speed the US government
allows most poultry plants
to run their assembly lines.
It’s a speed that helps chicken companies
stay profitable.
But if you ask poultry workers, they’ll
say it’s a speed that causes them pain.
Meat processing is a dangerous job in America.
Workers are 3 times more likely
to get seriously injured
than the average American worker.
More likely to get seriously injured than
people who work in oil and gas drilling
industrial building construction,
or people who operate sawmills.
And that was before the COVID pandemic
tore through meat plants.
Meat processing has a long history
of safety issues.
Using a sharp tool quickly and
close to other people is dangerous.
But some of the harm is avoidable, because
today, workers are without some basic protections
necessary to keep them safe.
So why has the US failed to protect the people
who process our meat?
Meat processing refers to the stages of turning
a live animal into a food product in a factory.
For poultry, a factory layout
might look something like this.
Workers hang live chickens by their feet on
a conveyor belt
where machines stun them,
cut their throats, defeather them
remove their heads and feet,
and take out their guts.
Then their carcasses are sanitized with an
acid solution before they get stored in a cooler.
This slaughtering section is
almost entirely automated
and it's the fastest part of the line.
But what happens next still requires
human precision.
Unless they are sold as whole chickens
workers cut up the carcasses into parts, by hand.
This process is called deboning.
That’s the job this worker has.
She works at a poultry plant in
northwest Arkansas.
And requested to remain anonymous for fear
of retaliation from her company.
She's worked in poultry processing
for over 20 years.
And it’s how she met her husband,
who died last year from COVID
after the virus spread through
poultry plants in the area.
Deboning work is extremely repetitive.
She's making those motions
thousands of times a day.
A 2014 CDC report found that, 34% of workers
suffer from carpal tunnel syndrome
and 76% of workers had nerve disorders
when working at standard speeds.
These conditions make the finger joints enlarged
and stiff, and give workers wrist pain
like these photos of poultry workers’ hands show.
Pace, repetition, and musculoskeletal disorders
also increase the odds of more severe injuries
which is why the poultry industry has more
reports of finger amputations
than any other industry.
And why the meat processing industry as a
whole averages 2 amputations a week.
Americans eat a lot more meat per capita today
than we did in the 60s.
But we actually eat less beef
and just a little more pork.
It’s because we eat a lot more chicken.
One reason is because chicken is comparatively cheap.
It’s less than half the cost of pork or beef.
If a meat processing company wants to keep
prices low and its profits high
they can adjust their output.
In other words, they can try to produce more
chicken with the same cost of labor.
That can be achieved through faster
slaughter line speeds.
The US Department of Agriculture regulates
meat processing line speeds.
But it’s primarily concerned with food safety.
Another agency, the Occupational Safety and
Health Administration, regulates worker safety
but doesn’t have the power to set
line speed limits.
Line speeds affect both food and worker safety
but regulating them through the USDA means
worker safety risks may be overlooked.
KELLOWAY: It's based on food safety standards.
It does not consider the effect
on workers at all.
In 2001, an OSHA “ergonomics rule went into
effect” “aimed at reducing injuries…
caused by a worker performing a repetitive
task,”
which could have empowered the agency
to regulate line speeds.
But within a year, Congress
“axed” the rule after
“business groups argued the standards
were too costly.”
Today, the National Chicken Council, the lobby
that represents the poultry industry
routinely asks the US government
to increase the maximum line speed.
Starting in 2018, the USDA granted waivers
to at least 54 plants to increase their line speeds
from 140 birds per minute to 175.
These 15 plants received those line speed
increases in 2020
even though they had been previously cited
for worker safety violations
and for severe injuries
according to a report by the
National Employment Law Project.
Evidence that worker safety
may not have been a consideration
when allowing faster speeds.
KELLOWAY: Humans are not machines
and there's just a limit to
human capacity for some of these
repetitive motions.
It’s not just line speeds that fall into
this gap in regulatory oversight.
It’s also why the amount of chemicals used
to prevent food-borne illness
like peracetic acid, ammonia, and chlorine
aren’t regulated for worker safety.
Chemical accidents like ammonia and chlorine
gas leaks injure hundreds of workers a year.
And they frequently make workers sick.
Absent stricter government regulation
to protect them
workers may feel they only have
one other option: unionization.
But that’s become out of reach
for most workers.
LICOLLI: I believe it's a mess.
Magaly Licolli organizes non-unionized
poultry workers in northwest Arkansas
through an organization called Venceremos.
She’s digging through her storage container
to find protest signs.
LICOLLI: This was when we were telling them
to shut down the factories because of the outbreaks.
This part of the country is crucial
for poultry production.
These three counties in Arkansas process more
poultry than almost anywhere in the US.
And multiple poultry companies
have plants here.
Including Tyson, one of the largest poultry
producing companies in the world
which has its corporate headquarters here
in Springdale, Arkansas.
That’s where Magaly is headed, to deliver
a petition in protest of working conditions
at a poultry plant also located in Springdale.
LICOLLI: Workers have been complaining a lot.
The working conditions have gotten worse,
even worse than the pandemic.
LICOLLI: There is less workers and workers
have to work faster.
LICOLLI: And the salary was the same.
The petition asks for a $4/dollar an hour
wage increase, no restrictions on bathroom
and water breaks, more frequent short breaks,
and paid sick leave.
When we reached out to Tyson for this story,
they wrote that they have “no reason to
deny breaks” to workers
and claimed the petition was “misrepresented”
to the workers who signed it.
Venceremos organizes poultry workers from
other companies in the area
who have had similar complaints
like this strike at a George’s poultry plant
in Springdale, Arkansas.
The work that Magaly’s organization does
is important in a state like Arkansas
where the vast majority of poultry workers
don’t have access to a union.
Unions have historically made dangerous jobs,
like slaughterhouses, a little safer.
But in the 1980s, union power declined,
in part due to a rise in anti-union politics.
Those trends hit the meat industry, too.
KELLOWAY: Unions once played a really important
watchdog role in both maintaining a wage floor
across the industry and maintaining
safety standards.
Pork and beef processing companies shuttered
unionized plants located in urban areas
and reopened non-union plants
in rural areas.
To meet this skyrocketing demand for chicken
starting in the 80’s
the poultry industry set up large plants
in rural areas, too.
Arkansas and other top poultry-producing states
have anti-union laws
and have some of the lowest
union membership in the country.
Meat processing workers are about twice as
likely to be a person of color
to not be a citizen, and to be foreign-born,
when compared to the total workforce.
LICOLLI: The majority of the workers working
in the northwest Arkansas are from
Central America, a lot of people
from Mexico
but also one of the biggest populations
is also people
from the Marshall Islands.
When unions began to decline
between 1980 and ‘90s
injuries in the meatpacking sector rose by 40%.
Since then, government data
shows that injuries have declined
a statistic the National Chicken Council
shows on their site
and roughly the same one they gave us
when we reached out to them for comment.
But there’s a debate about how reliable
that data is.
KELLOWAY: There's a lot of evidence that shows
reporting is down considerably.
There are a lot of worker-led and advocate-led surveys
that show persistent high levels of injury.
One of these surveys was given to Alabama
poultry workers.
72% of them said they suffered from
“significant work-related
injury or illness.”
That’s compared to 4.5% in the government’s
data on the whole country from that same year.
Because I've seen workers suffering,
you know, all these years.
They’ve had accidents, injuries that left
them disabled for life.
If they have babies, sometimes it's hard for
them to hold them because of the issues that
they have in their hands.
The poultry industry could make these workers’
lives a little easier—and, importantly,
safer by making modifications to this line.
Like reducing the speed, giving workers more
breaks, or minimizing repetition
by switching up job roles.
Paid sick leave is another improvement and
Tyson recently announced they would start
offering this benefit to workers in 2022
but only the vaccinated ones.
For now, Magaly continues her fight
on behalf of workers.
We went outside the Tyson headquarters.
The director of public relations was there
to receive the petitions.
I think that people really need to take into
consideration that
without these workers we don't have
food on our table.
And that's just facts.
It's just not only about the humanity but the
moral duties that we have to these workers.
Hi, thanks for watching this second episode
of our Future Perfect series on the meat industry.
Something that didn’t make it into this
story is the impact that this book had.
This is The Jungly by Upton Sinclair.
It's a novel that was published in 1906 about
the misfortunes of a Lithuanian family who
immigrates to the US to work in Chicago’s
meatpacking industry.
It was a best-seller of its day
and it was hugely influential.
Theodore Roosevelt who was president at the
time even credited the book for
inspiring him to pass the first
food safety regulation in the US.
But Sinclair apparently had hoped that the
focus would have been more on the workers
and the animals suffering in this system.
I talked to Claire Kelloway about this.
KELLOWAY: Sinclair, the author of The Jungle,
will often say
“I was aiming for readers’ hearts and
hit them in the stomach."